congresswoman debbie mccarsell powell
represents
florida's 26th district she joins me
today
uh congresswoman thanks for being on i
really appreciate your time
thank you for having me david the
florida vote
is very very interesting florida as a
state
may well determine who wins the
presidential election
joe biden or donald trump and then
within florida
your district may actually signal the
way that the state goes it's a very
interesting district as as you've
mentioned uh in other conversations
we've had
nearly 70 percent latino voters uh
talk a little bit about the dynamics
there in florida what are the most
important issues to floridians
well first let me say that you're
absolutely correct i think that the
state of florida
is going to be one of the most important
states in this election
the road to the white house begins in
florida and yes
it starts in florida's 26th district the
top issue here
has been and continues to be healthcare
healthcare access
i represent an area where um 70 of the
people that live in my district
are latinos hispanic from the hispanic
community
very diverse ecuadorians colombians
argentinians mexicans
many of them are cuban americans and for
them
during this pandemic this pandemic has
hit us very hard here in miami-dade
county we became the epicenter of the
of covid during the summer and it's
because of failed leadership locally and
at the state level
and many people lost their jobs they
didn't have access to quality healthcare
and the stakes of this election have
become even higher now that the senate
is trying to
push for that nomination to the supreme
court the supreme court as you know is
going to be hearing
the lawsuit to repeal the affordable
care act and
in my district david we have the second
largest number of people that get their
health care through the aca
300 000 individuals in my district have
pre-existing conditions
so if the aca is repealed you would see
millions of americans losing their
health coverage and so many here in my
district that would lose that and i can
tell you
that the energy in south florida it has
gone
up significantly in the past two months
people are out there
they're engaged there are so many
grassroots movements
going on in south florida they are
coming out for me
they're coming out for biden they
understand what's what's at stake at
this election
and uh because of their care because
they know who's going to protect their
care
i think that the energy has really gone
way above what anybody expected
within uh the american electorate
there are different groups that tend to
vote one way or the other
and as a general rule three of the most
left-leaning groups are jewish-americans
african-americans and latino or hispanic
americans
generally within that last group
cuban-americans tend to be the most
conservative and there seems to be this
kind of reflexive anti-castro thing that
that goes on and that we've seen
um can you address a little bit you know
your district is the perfect
place epicenter to see all of these
different groups as you mentioned and
their priorities and
and vote voting interests uh does
does the the perspective of the
cuban-american electorate
seem different this time around yeah and
you know there is a group of cuban
americans that are very much in favor of
donald trump
and that's because there has been a lot
of misinformation spread about the
democrats they are
instigating fear saying that um
you know accusing democrats of being
socialist which is completely false and
for cuban americans and for a lot of
people that have fled
violent regimes in latin america this is
scary and they've been using that
message to divide
to control that vote but i can tell you
that there's also a significant group of
cuban americans who are
100 behind joe biden they know that
donald trump
has been an ally of vladimir putin and
and let's
back up for a second vladimir putin is
propping up
the narco regime in venezuela the maduro
regime
they are propping up cuba they're one of
their top allies in cuba
and trump is standing right next to them
so um
cuban americans here and mary many latin
americans understand that
the person that they need to fear is
donald trump because we're seeing so
many signs
of someone that's trying to grab on to
power who's uh
doing whatever he can going towards the
road of an
authoritarian regime so cuban americans
here
are now standing up and saying no we do
not
support donald trump we are with biden
there's a group called
cubanos combined but there's also
ecuatorians
and and that's been a grassroots um
uh movement that has started really
by all the latin americans that are
living down here that have said
enough we're not gonna follow these eyes
anymore so i'm i'm very optimistic
and excited to see what's happening here
in south florida so
should we be concerned about the safety
of vote by mail
what do you see as again taking into
consideration all of the different
reasons one might vote one way or the
other
uh what what is your message to people
about how it is that they should vote if
they really want to feel good
about uh knowing feeling that their vote
is likely to be counted
what i tell everyone here is your vote
is still
going to be safe and secure do not let
anyone distract you or make you think
otherwise our six systems are secure we
have been
conducting oversight along with the fbi
we have been in communication with our
supervisor of elections here locally
so if you need to vote by mail because
of health conditions because you're not
here physically
mail that envelope today sign it seal it
mail it that's what we're saying just
send your ballot early
if you can vote early we start early
voting october 19th
and you can do that securely as well
wear a mask
use your hand sanitizer but vote
whatever
the plan is for you to vote vote vote in
the way that's safest for you for your
family
vote every vote counts david
in 2018 i had a colleague or one of the
candidates in texas
who lost her election by 900 votes
gina ortiz from texas who i think are
welcome into congress
in 2020 900 votes every single vote
counts
again if you have your ballot mail it in
sign it
mail it in send it it's safe it's secure
if you can vote in person vote early
don't wait until november third we have
two weeks of early voting here in
miami-dade and in monroe county
we can change the direction of this
country
and i i have a lot of optimism because
so many young people are excited
they're engaged they're telling their
parents their abuelos theos primos
primas
everyone to come out and vote and and
we're going to see that we're going to
see a huge turnout in 2020.
so this this is speculative it's just
your opinion but when do you believe we
will know
the election results if we vote
decisively
in florida if we have a decisive win in
florida that's going to be a
huge indicator that joe biden will be
our next president if joe biden wins
florida of course
that's what i'm referring to um if
we don't know it could take weeks
and so my recommendation is let all of
us
expect that uh don't fret don't
don't get anxious about it let's count
every single vote that's our democracy
we can be patient if we've waited this
long we can wait a couple of more weeks
but my hope is that florida is so
decisive
for joe biden that that will be a pretty
clear indicator
of who's going to take the white house
in january yeah it's um
it's it's going to be a very very
interesting election
extremely high stakes congresswoman
debbie mccarsell powell representing
florida's 26th
district thank you so much for your time
i really appreciate you joining me today
thank you david